dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Shana if I hear
genetic algorithms help us solve
problems that are very difficult if not
impossible to otherwise write programs
for for instance in this application we
have to build a simple car model to
traverse this terrain put some number of
wheels on it somewhere add a set of
triangles as a chassis and off you go
this is essentially the DNA of a
solution the farther it goes the better
the car is and the goal is to design the
best car you possibly can
first the algorithm will try random
solutions and as it has no idea about
the concept of a car or gravity it will
create a lot of bad solutions that don't
work at all however after a point it
will create something that is at least
remotely similar to a car which will
immediately perform so much better than
the other solutions in the population a
genetic algorithm then creates a new set
of solutions however now not randomly it
respects a rule that we call survival of
the fittest which means that the best
existing solutions are taken and mixed
together to breed new solutions that are
also expected to do well like in
evolution in nature mutations can also
happen which means a random changes are
also applied to the DNA code of a
solution we know from nature that
evolution works extraordinarily well and
the more we run this genetic
optimization program the better the
solutions get it's quite delightful for
a programmer to see their own children
trying vigorously and succeeding at
solving a difficult task even more so if
the programmer wouldn't be able to solve
this problem by himself let's run a
quick example we start with a set of
solutions the DNA of a solution is a set
of zeros and ones which can encode some
decision about the solution whether we
turn left or right in a maze or it can
also be an integer or any real number we
then compute how good these solutions
are according to our tastes in the
example with cars how far these designs
can get then we take for instance the
best three solutions and combine them
together to create a new DNA
some of the better solutions may remain
in the population unchanged then
probabilistically random mutations
happen to some of the solutions which
help us explore the vast search space
better reason repeat and there you have
it
genetic algorithms I have also coded up
a version of Roger or Singh's Everly's
our problem where the famous Mona Lisa
painting is to be reproduced by a
computer program with a few tens of
triangles the goal is to paint a version
that is as faithful to the original as
possible
this would be quite a difficult problem
for humans but apparently a genetic
algorithm can deal with this really well
the code is available for everyone to
learn experiment and play with and it's
super fun and if you're interested in
the concept of evolution maybe I read
the excellent book the blind watchmaker
by Richard Dawkins thanks for watching
and for your generous support and I'll
see you next time